hi there I'm Anna Prosser Robinson for
gamespot here at the WB booth at e3 2014
standing here with John Edwards who is
the lead designer for Mortal Kombat X
now what does a leave designer do you
know kind of charge of coming up with
what the characters actually do combat
wise you know game mechanics things like
that luckily we have a pretty open
studio at nether realms so everyone can
use their ideas and stuff in but we kind
of like you know as the as the designers
kind of you know Shepherd that movement
and make sure that we get the game
feeling as good as it can as far as
being the lead designer what would you
say was your your most passionate thing
you wanted to get across in Mortal
Kombat X what's your fingerprint that's
on this game yeah I think some of the
way the new characters fight we really
make sure that we introduce new
characters that they still feel like
Mortal Kombat characters and they you
know the depth is still there we've had
a lot of practice on some of the older
cares like scorpion sub-zero but with
new characters it's kind of you know
just out in the open of you know
everyone's expecting them to kind of fit
in so we do a lot of a lot of hard work
to make sure that that actually works
out and you have recently introduced two
new characters if I'm correct can you
introduce us to them tell us their names
you know what their style is gonna be
like sure yeah we have Devorah who is
like a human insect kind of a hybrid so
she has like these really cool like
spiky tentacles that are kind of like
inside of her body she can use for any
like stabbing attacks big combos which
is also able to use all these bugs that
live inside of her dials or you know we
know for a fatality things stuff like
that and then ferrets [ __ ] who is like
two characters in one like this big
brutish you know ogreish kind of a guy
with this little lady on his back that
kind of controls all of his movements
and they fight like as a team seen a lot
of you know big grappling moves but also
like really fast sharp attacks very cool
and those are joining some of the other
classic characters we've come to expect
oh yeah you know you've seen scorpion of
sub-zero but for sure there be a lot
more of them as well great and tell us a
little bit about the the style of this
game the fighting what it's gonna be
like is it gonna have any nods to
injustice or are we are we dealing
mostly with more of a Mortal Kombat base
what are we looking at yeah we try to
make all of our games feel you know like
like their own things so well it feels
more like you know Mortal Kombat 9
obviously being able to combat game we
learn new things every time we make a
fighting game and so we try to you know
make sure that we kind of you know bring
over some of that stuff but you know it
feels it feels kind of unique
that's a definite like mk9 flair to it
very nice you know we're looking at new
next-gen consoles moving forward and
you're talking about you know we want
each game to have something new
what are you enable to do by this new
technology that makes this game new and
fresh probably the big thing is graft
which the gore stuff were able to do so
you know we have all these crazy ideas
for fatalities and in x-rays at
NetherRealm and a lot of times we just
can't fully realize them because the
tech just isn't there yet this time it
seems like we're pretty much able do
anything we can swear you know punching
holes in bodies and slicing people's
faces off and things like that
everyone has tries to gross each other
out at the studio that's kind of what
makes the cut it did look pretty pretty
gross pretty violent and you know a very
exciting way what would you say is your
favorite animation you've seen so far in
terms of the grossing your co-workers
out oh there's lots of good ones I think
probably scorpion slicing a sub zero's
face off and having a face slide down
with a tongue wiggling in there
that one that would even gets us
sometimes it work you guys watch it and
everyone reacts
yeah you know you've done something
really well where like you know people
that have been used to making this game
for you know years and years they see
something there's like I do that's
pretty crazy so you know there's lots of
people who love fighting games there's
even a professional fighting game
community that's going to be interested
in this game and then there's also the
casual player who's just gonna want to
pick it up play with their friends go
through single-player even can you tell
us about the range of the game and and
how it's gonna be coming in as different
kinds of players yeah you know we always
do better when we try to make sure that
we you know get the casual guys
single-player content stuff like that
you know be a story and things but we
also really support the fighting game
community as a lot of people will know
so you know we've introduced like some
new mechanics this game like we have an
energy meter they will govern you know
how you can back - and you can run and
things like that so lots of like you
know fine-tuned you know mechanics for
the hardcore guys but if you're a casual
guy you just pick it up and have fun
beating your friend up and and bust out
a fatality every once in a while the
community of a game is is really
important what has the reception been
like for Mortal Kombat in in the
fighting game community and here at e3
so far really good we're super happy I
said we're trying to cater to a large
group of people so sometimes get a
little bit worried you know for maybe
going too far towards one of the other
but it seems like right now that
everyone is pretty hyped about it I
can't wait to see it develop thank you
so much for your time oh my pleasure
thank you let me know what you're most
excited to see in Mortal Kombat X by
tweeting at Anna Prosser with the
hashtag GameSpot III
you